Arithmetic operations on arrays
are always applied element wise.
Let's start with simple
multiplication operation.
Here we define a simple array so
that we can easily track the changes.
This will multiply each element by 2.
Let's check the output.
When using arithmetic operation,
a new array is created and
the values are stored in that array.
So our original array a still
holds the same values.
And this is our new array which we
get after multiplying array a by two.
Observe that,
it is element wise multiplication.
Let's try division.
Here we use the division operation to
divide each element of array a by two.
Let's check the output.
Observe that, when you divide 1 by 2,
you get a value 0 over
here instead of 0.5.
This is because both the array and
the divisor are integers.
If we were to do 2.0 instead of 2,
you will get float values.
Keep this point in mind before
performing division in general.
That is int divided by int will
give you an integer output.
To get float values,
you need at least, the numerator or
the denominator to be a float value.
Let's check the output.
Observe that, we could successfully get
a floating point value instead of 0.
How about arithmetic
operation using two arrays?
We will start with addition.
We create another array
b with these values.
Now, let's just add a and
b using the plus operator.
As mentioned, this is element wise.
This is our new arraya plus b.
One important thing to note
here is that the shape of a and
b should be similar before the operation
a plus b, else it will throw error.
Similar to the addition,
you can perform subtraction.
Now, let's move ahead with
multiplying two arrays.
This is interesting, because unlike
other many metrics languages
multiplication operator
when used with two array
will not give you metric product, but
will do element wise multiplication.
That is,
element at position 0,0 in array
a is multiplied only with
the element at position 0,0 in b.
Let's print the multiplication
of matrix a and b.
Can you also element
wise multiplication?
But the next question would be,
what about matrix multiplication?
How do you achieve that?
Like, for everything,
Num Pi has a function.
It has function called dot,
which performs matrix multiplication.
Similar to multiplication,
division of two arrays can be performed.
Just include division of
operators between the two arrays.
Let's check the output.
As seen before, since array a and
b are indigenous, we get the final array
in the form of indigenous as well.
If you want to see floating values,
convert one of the arrays to float.
Well, that's all for now.
Keep practicing.